good old infidelity it's like holy
bananas definitely have some like whoa
to that but not like whoa today we are
ranking the juiciest family secrets from
y'all the BuzzFeed community we're
ranking they've gotten from lamest
mositure
i get i want it to be like very juicy
family secrets cuz I feel like I have a
lot within my own family and I'm hoping
that everybody's kind of on like my same
you know like me my friends we used to
always call each other like G samosa
because we just love it yeah it means
like Gossip Girl in Spanish she's lost I
let's go that team so I guess I'm
excited do you have any family secret no
my family is boring okay my mother's
paternal family was full of actual
Satanists they were even investigated a
few years ago by the state of Kansas
because some evidence possibly linking
them to human sacrifices was unearthed
on the old farm where they used to live
but nothing conclusive was found
apparently a few of them are now dead
and those that aren't are lying low wait
a minute so they might have killed
people we don't know for sure sounds
like they definitely murdered well I
read that Satanists aren't actually that
bad of people yeah treacherous Satan
itself is like you know yeah I heard
there chill ready buddy go I'm gonna
give it a solid 6 I'm also gonna give it
a solid 6 and together we almost make
the number 666 what people died maybe it
also said that there's no conclusive
evidence and who's to say it actually
happened I could say that right now
maybe I sacrificed somebody how are you
guys gonna know don't look me up uncle
so you just said she's hacker right
yeah okay I thought my stepfather had
been awarded custody of me and my
half-brother in 1990 I found out in 2015
he actually kidnapped us
he died in 2005 when I was 24 so he was
never punished and we never understood
what truly happened to us my biological
mom had been trying to find us for the
first five to six years we finally got
in contact with her what I feel like
someone kidnapping you and you not
knowing that you're kidding you thinking
hey Dad is your parent and he actually
could have to go why I'm buying this an
eighth floor I think that I have heard
of stories like this about like custody
problems becoming like a kidnapping
issue because legally it wasn't a
custody thing I felt like sound really
bad right now don't kidnap that's bad
okay number three my
great-great-grandmother was widowed
eight times she managed to amass a
considerable amount of wealth from her
misfortunes alright that's pretty juicy
I mean like eight times there's a lot
that happens and having a lot sometimes
food today
mysteriously disappear eight times in
our own exactly
maybe after like the third time she was
like I have so much money now maybe I
can keep doing this talent yes yep you
know I judges and I think goes that's
that's where I wanted that okay custody
number four
my grandmother married my mom's
ex-boyfriend my mom broke up with a guy
because she thought there was something
going on with him and my grandmother and
now he's her stepfather I'm gonna give
it a 5/5 I gave it a 7
cuz that's whack six for me I mean just
because I'm thinking about like the mom
living with this yeah and like a man
that she used
the intimate with is now has stepfather
one Wow I gave that up three really I
mean you see that on like Jerry Springer
if your mom and your grandmother is
closer in age also how is it boyfriend's
and he can be in the middle I'm like
this isn't it this could be a very
normal day five my great great
I have no idea how many greats
grandfather is rumored to have had a
homosexual relationship with Abraham
Lincoln
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they really should with any blinkin me I
give it a four
I give it five yeah I think it's cool I
know sure it's not it's not I don't
think it's juicy
sorry it's a eight I think
Abraham Lincoln it's so far in the past
sex 10/10 I think in a historical
context I mean as far as the masses go
mm-hmm it's gonna that's gonna shake up
shake up a lot of fellas making history
should go from historic American history
as we know it says my dad's real father
left when he was young and until a year
ago we didn't even know his name
when we finally found out we loved him
up online and saw he's one of the heads
of the Polish mafia and wanted for 70
plus murders okay this is pretty cool
that's a cool secret like to like
finally cool I'm gonna call it a six
seven I was like yeah
what are you thinking I'm just thinking
that like finding all that anyone is a
part of like the Polish mafia Russian
mafia like that's just guy stuff you
read about and hear about movies but
then to actually have that happen to you
and you're like oh well we come to your
for yeah I think that was a good example
you had other like how do how
comfortable what I feel saying in or
thing I would tell everybody right which
would have you drag about it
25:10 neutral I give it I give it a 7
just because I think that's a that's a
cool secret I mean it's not cool that he
murdered I just think that like if I
were to find out my grandfather was a
mafia boss I'd be like doh
my great-grandmother raised my
grandfather as her own a generous deed
after having pushed his actual mother
out a window telling her okay I wasn't
ready this is a short one I thought no I
wasn't sure where I was gonna go way
given that I can eat oh I gave it a I
gave it a solid what I all the time
literally because I have the whole story
I'm kind of both on yeah yeah
and that's up there yeah I just it's
again horrifying wouldn't like hesitate
to tell people but I'd tell people be
like yeah we're not sure if it's true
but if it is true only a few years ago
we found out my father has a mistress
and a love child recently he confessed
that the child isn't the only one who's
had outside of his marriage to my mother
scheme although he has five other
children and two of them are close
family friends I went from two siblings
to seven in a week
good old infidelity that classic family
I'm gonna give it a seven it said go to
families and careers whether you have
one children always more time Rachel
don't judge with your feelings let's
judge it on juice five seven I give it a
5 I feel like you know infidelities
everywhere that's wild
lots of kids that's a lot of college
tuitions I'm sure he's nothing
are you ready for this one my dad's
parents are cousins I'm gonna call that
a six six - yeah seven um that ten again
ten yes I'll give it a four I'm gonna
say yeah weird it sounds like it's
great-great-great grandparents like kids
like ran your grandma's like I know
people whose grandparents are a lot like
that's very that's very recent for it to
be that is very recent it is everyone
shunned from the are they shunned from
the family like I don't know it's
literally just like my dad's parents are
cousins mic drop
so my great-grandfather was a stolen
baby my great-great grandmother let's
call her Gigi was on her deathbed when
the doctor asked my grandma how many
children Gigi had given birth to that's
what my grandmother's pulled her out of
the room and explain the truth Gigi
apparently gave birth to a baby who
didn't survive but wasn't going to leave
the hospital without a baby so she's
decided the best course of action was to
steal a baby nobody knows how she got
away with it or how she got her fingers
on a legal birth certificate
I'm so glad this is last Wow
that's up I'm gonna give it a seven for
them like that it's original yeah it is
original thing I've heard people
stealing a baby before I give it an
eight I was gonna give a seven but it's
still like a pretty juicy story totally
how the secret Wow
I thought we learned a lot I don't know
if we learned a lot we saw I feel very
educated just yeah it makes me feel like
all families are crazy and that is the
fun well these are like pretty good rosy
secrets very good and I love them all
and they weren't as scary as I thought I
felt like I was gonna get really upset
yeah like really freaked out but these
are like very normal and like I feel
like every family has yeah question
everything question your parents
question your grandparents don't trust
anybody nothing's true nothing matters
yes that's what we take away from them
you're like really do you like families
look like a societal made up construct
that doesn't really exists right
[Music]